- Have any of your friends
ever told you that they
think I'm good looking?
(giggling)
- No.
- True.
(upbeat music)
- I guess I just want her to be honest.
And I just want us to laugh.
Ultimately, just embarrass
the (beep) out of each other.
- Jennifer is the biggest
liar in the family, easily.
And when I say the family, I mean...
I don't just mean the nuclear family,
I mean the entire extended family.
- I think she tells all kinds
of unnecessary white lies.
- I would strongly warrant caution here,
because whatever you say to
me to try and embarrass me,
I will make it ten times worse for you.
(suspenseful music)
- Do you think you're funnier than me?
- No.
- Oh my god.
- 100% no.
- True.
- Oh my god, honey bun.
- You're welcome.
- That's so nice of you.
- Have you ever spit in my food?
- Yes.
- True.
(giggling)
- When did you spit in my food?
- I'm sure I've done it multiple times.
- Have you ever had a threesome?
- No.
- True.
- I was kinda hoping you had.
- Does your boyfriend think I'm cool?
- Yes.
- That's a lie.
(giggling)
- He's never said you're uncool.
- Steve, I'm coming for you.
- Who do you think is better looking?
You or me?
- You.
- True.
- Why are you so disappointed?
Like, you came here to fight.
- I wanted to fight.
- I'm a nice person.
(suspenseful music)
Do you think I'm a good person?
- Yes.
- True.
- Woohoo! Finally.
- Oh my god.
- I might've saved you
from a lot of (beep).
- Do you get jealous when I'm successful?
- No.
- True.
- Cool.
- Have you ever been attracted
to any of my ex-boyfriends?
- No.
- That's a lie.
- Oh god.
- Have you ever been in love?
- No.
- That's a lie.
(giggling)
- Who is it?
- I mean, I love my dogs,
and I love my parents.
- Do you enjoy living with me?
- Yes.
- That's a lie.
(giggling)
- If you're not an
honest person, like then,
there is no trust, and
there's no foundation there.
So that sucks.
- For the most part, I think
everyone should be honest,
or else it's gonna come
bite you in the ass.
- So the fact that the things
that she lied about were,
I feel like they were minimal.
They were more like, hilarious.
But I love that we still have
a strong, honest foundation.